in our series a more perfect union we
aim to show that what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us I love this series and today
we're talking about millions of small
businesses all across the country
struggling amid restrictions during the
pandemic but there's a husband-wife duo
behind a Virginia nonprofit that found a
way to help local small businesses keep
going
and now as chip Reid shows us their
successful approach is being copied from
coast to coast he just lost his father
eight weeks ago right when all this hit
and their business has been down
sixty-five percent and when I told him
that he was funded he said I have goose
bumps
I'm goose bumps I know my father is
looking down on me I know he's
protecting me Wow Pete Schneider is
talking about the old town deli a
30-year old restaurant in Alexandria
Virginia that he was able to help
through the Virginia 30-day fund the
nonprofit which he created with his wife
Burson provides forgivable loans of up
to $3,000 for Virginia based small
businesses that have been open for at
least a year to apply business owners
submit short videos explaining why they
need the loan could be losing the
business it has been incredibly
meaningful to see how many people
actually really need this and they're
all telling us this is just helping us
just bridge that gap until the federal
funding comes so that we can make a go
of it all they ask is that if businesses
get back on their feet they give the
$3,000 to another small business in need
so far they've raised more than 1.5
million dollars and funded more than 180
small businesses
including Sol taco in Richmond Virginia
Trey Owens opened the restaurant less
than two years ago he was born and
raised in Richmond and wanted a
restaurant that celebrated diversity and
honored his enslaved ancestors I don't
mind working hard because I know my
history and I know where I come from my
great-great-great great-grandfather
worked and died with nothing to show for
it just me the restaurant had already
won best taco in the state and business
was booming until the coronavirus hit we
had to do something I didn't want to
close because my idea for so taco was
for it to be a community staple he
turned his restaurant into a marketplace
to sell fresh produce to locals
delivered food to hospitals and sold $2
tacos to service workers so you're
losing a little money there but you're
helping the community right right but
the help from Virginia 30-day fun
allowed us to kind of get that program
going and get it off the ground how
grateful are you to the Snider's for
what that gun has been in contact with
me constantly he's been talking to me
about anything that he can do to help me
to keep the business going Pete is an
angel the Snider's model has been so
successful that other states including
Georgia Pennsylvania Arkansas and
California have started replicating it
is it your hope that this just goes
national people want to help out during
this crisis and hopefully this inspires
people to have it spread across the
nation it's a lot of work but we are
very fulfilled by it and it's fun for us
to get to work together on something it
just feels good to be passionate about
something again I'm fortunate that I've
had a lot of different experiences this
has been the best damn job I've ever had
a job that has kept businesses like Sol
taco open despite the covin pandemic
your dream is still alive my dream is
still alive my grandmother who I learned
how to cook from she never stopped
so her memory and everything that she
taught me just keeps me going and I'm
not stop I want sometimes it's about
more than just the money it's about hope
and right now we could all use some of
that for CBS this morning
chip reader Charlottesville Virginia
well done there chip Reid soul taco
looks very tasty I will say that I will
also say that's a wonderful passing on
the loan what I think is wonderful about
it in part is that it's a video
application they'll accept just a video
you know no reams of paperwork
complicated ID numbers this that and the
other thing Gail I know you saw that too
tawny first let's just say Bravo to the
Snider's but I love that you picked up
all this old taco because I tell you I
lost hearing after that the thing looks
so good I just stopped myself from
licking the monitor so if ever I'm in
the area I want to go to Trey's place it
looks so good I love a good taco you
could tell by the meat you could tell by
the show you could tell that was good
eating
but again Bravo to the Snider's and also
Anthony it's perfect example of when you
pay it forward really good things happen
you never go wrong when you pay it for
yep yep and and what you're talking
about $3,000 makes the difference
between life or death for a business
here and that's what you're seeing with
with Sol taco and these other businesses
they're helping and I love that when
when they're back on their feet they pay
for it it's just it's a great program
it's a really great program